you know Sir Patrick Stewart and you
don't really use the surra much do you
sorry so I've been calling you know I
shouldn't am I supposed to know
okay but no do you I take my lead from
Sir Ian I whom we've both shared some
time with yes and he is he is so
phlegmatic about all of that and and I
just you know it's a great honor but
it's not something that I need to press
when you bump into another sir when
you're out and about do you then do you
roll in sir circles circles
[Applause]
so how do you become a sir
well Patrick how well you know it's a
case of I got mine on the Queen's
Birthday Honours but you have reminded
me that I did have a sir encounter only
a few weeks ago in Los Angeles
a rather fancy in fact extremely fancy
restaurant
tell them what it is they'll know it was
the the tower bar
no
[Applause]
you keep going I got a feeling this
isn't gonna work out so we're the four
of us were seated at a table about 15
minutes later into the restaurant walks
Sir Paul McCartney Wow good look Paul
and I have a very slender relationship
but it's lasted decades encountered him
in 1964 no when his girlfriend Jane Asha
then had told him that I loved Aston
Martin's I was driving a battered old
Ford but Aston Martin's were my dream
car
she told him this and one night yeah we
knew he was seeing the show there was a
knock on my door and I said yeah come in
I'm there in my underwear
no like as usual
[Laughter]
I'm ready for you
and the door opened standing there was
Paul McCartney who I had never met
before and this was 1964 he said J says
that you like Aston Martin's here drive
this and he tossed a bunch of keys and
it was ass we're now in the tower Baro
[Applause]
I am feeling less he sees me and comes
over and I stand up say hi and we have a
big hug in the restaurant and I'm very
much aware that there's all the tables
are full on this kind of thing and we
talk for five or six minutes and he goes
and sits down five minutes go by and
into the restaurant walks sir Ringo
Starr I swear to you they were they were
oh they were at the same table they were
the same yes well we at the tower free
meal
we finish early and I get up to go and
Paul stands up to say goodbye and we
have a hug and this we have a hug he
says into my ear
do you know Ringo I've never met him but
I'm rego come on come over here hang on
a minute he said sir Ringo sir Patrick
sir Paul hey we've got the knights of
the round table
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]